Sam and I are gearing up for lifelines I
start shooting in a couple weeks one of
the things we're trying to solve is one
bill to see where footage might look
like in final color graded forum on set
now usually when you're on set recording
with the digital camera it's hard to get
a judgment of what the final image might
look like so we are going to solve that
using something called lookup date you
think of a lookup table like a ulti an
Instagram filter you've probably heard
of logarithmic video profiles or flat
picture profiles and the idea behind
those is that they save as much
information in your video file as
possible so the problem is it looks ugly
it's really hard to tell what kind of
picture you're getting this is a flat
gray wash it was a small HD 502 monitor
this monitor let me actually load up the
look-up tables into the monitor and
apply them in real times the footage for
example this is a log image right here
on the camera and I can do in real time
in this monitor I can apply a lookup
table and I can see what the collection
it's all pretty and colored rated here
you can see the dull flat the clothes
are kind of you know unsaturated but
over here is really punchy really
contrasting really vibrant let me show
you guys a little bit more detail on
look-up tables how to use them we can
get them how you can make your own and
what it does to your footage so if
you're shooting a mug on your camera
your image probably looks like this flat
washed out milky grays
no keep blacks so I know I'm in DaVinci
do in Chi is a free program you can go
download it for free just go to google
black magic is a company that makes it
all DaVinci Resolve wonderful for color
grading you can make your own look-up
tables and it really really easily so
we're going to fly a lookup table to
this footage real quick here I'm going
to go this clip here's a cool shot of me
looking out in the distance like a tough
dude all right click on the clip here
I'm going to 3d look-up tables I have a
bunch I've already added but the film
looks come with DaVinci boom
all right so now I switch as a lookup
table applied to it and notice it
actually looks really dark you can look
up tables they're not smart they can't
tell where your footage is coming from
it's just going to do a simple
conversion of one value to another the
thing is all this raises writings for my
footage a little bit and now
wonderful but now everything is very
contrasting very punchy before after
before all washed up actor before after
notice my skin tones here really pop all
these colored lights in the background
it looks very washed out the lookup
table applied it pop very nicely what
you're like that one you do you're like
I kind of like that one you can't like
like this one I like that one along with
balance grip girl bro is that what has
this that one has like it stylish
yeah little flat yeah it's okay I can
not that that we go back I like that
you're like major come into the present
party log our silent table commands like
that silence whisper at least like looks
like we're not all right
Columbian cafe that's not bad is this
brighter red Nico yes ock my barking you
yeah you go with red now wine we go okay
we go haha
that brown haze we go he has a smoggy
mocha brown ball red light district you
know this is pretty clean yes I mean
remedy you can still go ahead and
continue to correct a footage after
applying a lookup table so you can model
look-up tables get you most of the way
there and then you can tweak your little
bit more from there it means very
similar to Instagram Instagram filters
are basically look-up tables being
applied to your phone's pictures and
then you can still from there tweak your
saturation your brightness and that kind
of stuff you can actually make your own
lookup table very very simple here's a
shot of me dramatically looking down to
the ground and so I could make my own
lookup table here I could increase the
contrast a little bit maybe raise my
highlights just a little bit you want
for home green look of table charlie
just raise the contrast purple and green
this is for Nick as everything you ever
wanted purple and green i'ma try to
action make it kind of look
still it's almost perfect I'm gonna do
my little trick here which is to go to
my saturation there's the luma and
desaturate my dark my blacks return to a
neutral black mmm nice nice and purple
dinging there you have a Nick I hope
you're happy
we finally done the complete so now I
can actually take this and I can export
a lookup table out of DaVinci it's
really really simple
all you do is you click on the clip that
you worked on you go generate tricky
lookup table
and I can save it somewhere else into
the desktop I'll fire it Romania and I
can apply this lookup table too so any
piece of footage I want to but I can
also put this back on that monitor that
small HD 502 and I can preview my
footage through that lookup table okay
so I fired up a mirror here and I
grabbed a random clip from the same
night so here it is in log all flat low
contrast II you know some purple and
green would really go a long way so here
we go I'm going to this X here I'm going
to apply lumetri luma tree is Premier's
basic color grading effects filter
things you can apply look at pages of it
if I go to the input lookup table and I
go to browse here we are the desktop
Nick special boom and now even though
I'm not in the Vinci I get the exact
same color grade that just made me
DaVinci Here I am with no purple and
green you know I'm not going to lie it
actually doesn't look that bad
mmm a purple blue shine off the gun a
little bit of green highlight this
actually looks pretty good I'm not going
to lie
okay so there's actually a lot of great
free look-up tables online it will
submit they should make a pack of like
150 lookup table so it's only $25 and
they all look amazing I will link the
description
Sedona is one of my favorite for you
lookup table that are out there I'll
just apply this here and this is a
really nice like cinematic lookup table
it's not super conventional and like it
actually handles contrast and colors
like really nicely love links in the
description to some or table lookup
tables for you guys to look up some are
free some are hope you guys found it
useful once again punch the links in the
description below those useful guys
we've made a collection of all of our
favorite tutorials whether or not you're
a filmmaker these are interesting fun to
watch and actually kind of entertaining
so go ahead and click on the link on the
screen sit back and enjoy some learning